oh-ho-ho [ __ ] going bro [ __ ] - welcome
to Christmas shopping simulator - we
play the other one a year ago time class
flies fast bike - English how to [ __ ]
this away ah this game is made by the
company game to market their game anyway
they look like they stepped it up a bit
in this one we got the average Joe and
with different outfits Wow we got please
no fly ice-cream sandwich guy who has
zero dignity I can relate to that and 12
years left on our boat I can relate to
that as well so let's start with my wife
my ice cream sandwich guy let's do this
it's sorry some black front oh god is
Black Friday oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off it's
mine
holy [ __ ] I don't want to go to game I
need to enter chefing Shand ruffington's
where the [ __ ] is chapping oh it's right
here I like the music
it makes me want to dance ah I'm sorry
okay I need a hurry up because what the
[ __ ] are you doing mate grab green oh
it's right here
there we go I did it only I can dance
only I can dance pick show bleep [ __ ]
that guy got [ __ ] all right what's our
next goal for the bank
my my beloved Edgar ah I'm gonna buy him
a TV box at TV and curry
oh Jesus Christ are crazy over there
guys stop running it's dangerous gotta
get the hundred inch TV I don't know
what's going on but I think I got it
yeah for the brave for Edgar [ __ ] off oh
damn
some Michael Bay [ __ ] in this oh this is
for the bay she got kinky kitty get her
a cat [ __ ] mask at the pet Provocateur
now that is some sexy [ __ ] I'm so sorry
now that is some sexy cow well toe the
[ __ ] of my arms doing I don't think I'm
doing it right that [ __ ] is this game
game step up your game I don't know
what's going on that was a challenge
like 150 but oh my god I can't stop
sliding I can't stop sliding help I
never asked for this life help
all I wanted was to do Christmas
shopping best game
good job game Oh what the [ __ ] is this
the [ __ ] mate what what ah okay uh
all right so there's a secret code in
this game not a lot of people will know
about it promise me promise me you won't
say anything about it okay secret
between us
submit there we go we found it we got
the end character he's got five in
arrogance
seriously seriously but the company open
company let me double double double you
kidding are you kidding me right now
I'm a [ __ ] ant best game here we go
yeah all right I think we can afford
yeah we got money now do you need help
lady ha ha ha
Jesus she always lands on her feet a
shoe your [ __ ] kitty cat oh my god
she's parkour expert what is this mine
yes all right grandma
burn in hell [ __ ] oh my god
that I've seen some strange gang banks
in my day but this one takes the price
I'm not even in the car anymore ah ah I
got a fedora now like I don't really
that was a secret
oh man life is a fedora where it really
is [ __ ] lame is [ __ ] Jesus Christ is
the game going to crash I would bet five
bucks yes the game crashed I win five
bucks thanks boots
okay every here we [ __ ] go let's get
the [ __ ] [ __ ] mask
oh my god I'm surfing people [ __ ] off
all right here we go
the [ __ ] mask is mine push out [ __ ]
there you go I bought it for my dad my
dad Oh God Oh Oh what is this oh oh
excuse me it's this is Santa I'm a big
fat [ __ ]
that's right I'm Santa now [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] off Santa I'm saying that
you're not Santa I'm Santa naki where
are you Nucky come here baby there you
are my sweet sweet
did you know yogi is actually potatoes
not pasta this game is not cultural [ __ ]
yo it's potatoes oh [ __ ] is this a
portal uh no no no thank you
No thank you very much oh this is the
one but then what oh it's a sonic level
gotta go so rad
I did a how do I even play this game
like I don't where I don't hi
I have this now we go to the me up for
the PIA coming in the throw up there we
go okay Oh also you can take selfies in
this game I don't know why and I don't
think I'm very good at selfies something
tells how there we go I think I actually
got one but I don't know how much longer
I can play this honestly I love it I
love it more on ten out of ten [ __ ] 10
out of 10 10 out of 10 fit another 10
all right that was Christmas shopping
simulator - have you done your Christmas
shopping yet I sure hope so because
otherwise this is what you're in for
just just buy online just buy online
you'll save you a lot of trouble that's
my little tip of the day as in exchange
maybe you can leave a little like maybe
you can subscribe if you haven't already
you probably am alright that's it for
now so much stay awesome
would you rather know when you will die
or know how you die Oh